hey babe i'm coming to your town to do
stand up chrisdcomedy.com
we got boston philadelphia eatontown new
jersey pittsburgh pennsylvania wakeegan
illinois nashville tennessee
i'm coming this summer all the way
through october chris d
comedy go get tickets now
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
[Music]
[Applause]
you know i met phil collins once did i
ever tell you this
no i never told you that i met phil
collins
i have proof of that i think i would
remember that he's a
he's an icon icon how about this
so first of all he was he is he was he's
still alive right i mean
philly with us he's he's alive and he's
listening
shout out phil shut up phil so i got
courtside seats philip collins
phil collins i got courtside seats to
the
uh new york knicks game uh this was
three years ago easter sunday
last place knicks versus the second to
last place philadelphia 76ers
so we sit down okay and our courtside
seats which were fantastic
i i i forgot how i got them it was like
one of those things where like somebody
canceled and
they had the seats available so like i'm
50th on the list and they called me
so i showed me and my father so my
father
and i my father had never been i've
never been quartzite at that moment
crazy
it was crazy unbelievable great
experience my father
sits down in our seats and it's it's me
my father and phil collins
sitting next to my dad so yeah
so my dad first of all my dad doesn't
know that it's phil collins okay he has
no idea
that it's phil collins people are coming
up and yelling stuff you know at him and
whatever he has no clue that this is
phil collins
so my father also by the way in the pr
ins
at some point during the game asked me i
looked down and he goes chris can you
take a picture
and i look down my dad has his shoe and
his sock off
with his bare foot on the court at you
have to be kidding me no swear to god
he's got his bare foot
on the court and i'm like what are you
doing dad he's like i want to just put
my foot he's like i'd be funny send your
stepmother a picture of my foot on
on a basketball i'm like yeah it's a
great thing dad
so i'm like no put your shoe and your
sock back on
he's got he's got bare crusty foot
in four thousand dollar seat yeah a 70
year old
diabetic collins is looking at his bare
foot yeah well phil collins was sitting
there eating a bag of easter candy
the entire time i swear to god he's
literally eating cadbury eggs and other
types of chocolate
either yeah he's he first of all
there's a policy where you can't bring
in any outside food or beverage
into mountain square garden where did
phil collins get a bag of he's gonna get
a big goddamn easter candy because i
didn't get a bag of easter candy oh they
don't have
bags of easter he bro he's smuggled in
easter candy he's
the british are weird that's that means
that at a specific moment he was looking
at the bag of candy and he goes well i'd
have to smuggle it in
yeah and then he was like i'm gonna do
it yeah phil collins
phil collins bag of easter candy so he's
eating easter candy
a security guard has to come over and
say sir would you please put your shoe
and sock back on
i said to the security guard i swear to
god i asked him right there i said sir
how long have you been working madison
square garden
he said 25 years i said in all of your
25 years i've ever had to ask someone
sitting courtside to please put their
shoe
and sock back on and he says actually no
i said well i could have guessed that
but that was actually no
then my father asked one of the ball
boys to please
this is 2017. oh sorry 2018.
my father asked one of the ball boys if
there was a possibility
that he could get for me a signed
basketball from patrick
patrick ewing i was gonna say patrick
hasn't played for the knicks since the
early 2000s
okay and the ball boy says i can get
your signed ball but patrick ewing
unfortunately tonight as he hasn't been
in the last 10 years
is not in the building so
so i'm like dad why are you first of all
i'm a grown man why are you asking for
signed basketballs from players
your dad is great because your dad
operates on like two cylinders that are
constantly banging
yes one is like clueless holy cow i've
never seen anyone like this man
but then all of a sudden he's asking for
a signed patrick patrick universal and
it's
both are endearing well yeah your dad i
would love to see a documentary on your
dad or i'd love to see
i'd love to see your dad's parents your
grandparents i want to know
how your dad came to be well homeless
pimp and i are gonna film a documentary
about my dad so
that's gonna happen we're gonna go down
to tampa florida my dad now lives
in tampa tampa toni we're gonna go down
there and film him um
so yeah he's a wild character but so so
we're at the game easter sunday e
phil conzi in the easter candy my dad's
asking for signed basketballs from
patrick ewing
i'm mortified so all of a sudden
the new york knicks staff come over and
they're putting
they they go to they with their camera
equipment and they go to put phil
collins on the jumbotron right so my dad
goes why would they
turns to me in full volume he goes why
would they put this [ __ ] up on the
screen
no so he and again he doesn't know that
it's
that he still has no idea that that's
phil collins i'm like because it's phil
collins dad
he goes who from bon jovi
[Laughter]
didn't he think stephen tyler was from
bonjour that's why i'm bringing him bon
jovi he thought stephen tyler was bon
jovi anybody and oba is is bon jovi so
he goes who from bon jovi because that's
just my dad's thing
we should call him tony bon jovi he has
no idea what bon jovi is he goes oh okay
he goes from banjo i said it's phil
collins and he goes
name one of his songs and then with that
they start going
douche i can feel it yeah i mean sally
you have to understand the crowd
is erupting oh that's that's an arena
song yeah
erupting clapping 18 000 people do you
do they go and they're going going crazy
in the phil collins is waving at the
jumbotron right next to my father
my dad goes i've never heard this song
i was like what you come on you've never
heard this song
i said dad it's phil collins there's a
girl that's been on my mind
all the time hey hey hey babe
nice um hey babe so
so he puts phil collins up on the
jumbotron uh the new york knicks staff
crushing with you in the air tonight 18
000 people whatever sold out capacity
was
ms grant garden clapping going nuts they
literally i've never seen this ever in
my life they dim the lights
for a jumbotron shout out like literally
dim the lights he's one of the biggest
living he's one of the biggest living
musicians of all time of
all time okay they take a they take a
you know
two seconds put the camera down because
it's still in a new york mix timeout
then they put the camera on me
i i i hope they played in the air
tonight as well
no they put the camera on me and i
believe we have my name my last name is
spelled d-i-s-t-e-f-a-n-o
they put up on the jumbotron chris
c-h-r-i-s-d-e-s-t-a-f-a-n-o so they have
my name spelled wrong name wrong
yeah and then they put a clip they put a
clip up of
some msg show i did called the bracket
where i'm legit
50 pounds heavier i look like
uh just a few followers follow phil
khan's literally
the the clip is playing not a single
person
not a single person's making sound the
only thing i could hear
was one of the ball boys dribbling the
basketball chewing gum not even looking
in my direction i swear and again
there's footage of this
my somebody while i'm playing when you
know when it's over and you're waving
yeah at the camera when phil collins was
getting a standing ovation
i hear somebody scream from the upper
deck who is that
that's what that's pretty good and the
only thing throughout it while
i swear the only thing throughout it
that i even remember
because it was like traumatizing is i
felt my father's hand slowly rubbing the
middle of my back
saying to me it's going to be over soon
champ
he goes yeah this is the clip they look
at look at the tips on that
oh my god yeah so that's my phil
constructor oh and then oh
you're in a structure shirt yep and then
after that after that bomb of a thing
you know of of me even phil collins felt
bad i swear to god he passed down his
easter
campaign and i got a piece of his easter
game awful collins is a guy what a guy
what a guy i had a um my first actually
my only court side i have a courtside
next story
really i yeah so um well it's simple
you've only went to courtside once
uh i've been to the knicks games a few
times but sometimes a few rows back but
like crossroads
dead center right it was like walt
frazier it was like somebody
it was someone was like uh the first
seat right it was like i forget who was
like
an old nick right right but like like a
hall of fame i forget who i feel bad
but um but then so right right away i
want to tell you your skin looks
fantastic
thank you so much it really does it
looks great yeah i actually i bought a
new um
exfoliator right and uh it's it's
actually
like it's meant to not be too rough on
the skin and you've got a haircut a lot
of fans are saying oh why isn't that got
a haircut
you got you got a haircut so you you
braved it and you went long i like to go
short
and now it's short and you got and you
got a haircut yeah great thank you
yeah so so it's me right so then i get
this i'm like oh my god i'm nervous
right i'm like this i can't believe i'm
sitting courtside right right
i sit down dexter's with me
and then it's my buddy dexter uh my
manager and then shout out dex
not not dexter the serial killer from
showtime no no not that dexter that
would be fun though
if that dexter was your manager if he
got out of serial killing and
managing you that'd be fantastic 100
yeah yeah so it's so it's a knicks hall
of famer and i'm forgetting who
and then it's it's me and dex and then
it's matthew broderick's son
matthew broderick so so this is what
happens okay this is we're sitting i'm
like i can't believe this oh who's gonna
be sitting next to me that's what i was
thinking when i was going there
so dead center was sitting down there
playing the bulls
okay i believe it was a triple overtime
game really fantastic game
and um oh no actually they might have
also been playing was it i went another
time they're playing lebron anyway i
can't remember
so you got you were there for them
playing lebron wow
seeing lebron james up close in person
it has to i would imagine just
it would depress me because of how what
a physical specimen
and unbelievable like athlete he is and
i just am not that
it's it's actually um oh it's amazing
it's it's amazing because what happens
is every time he touches the ball every
time
the whole you see the old stand just get
up and be like just
hanging on i mean every time he touches
the ball it's just like
he's got it he's got it and it's just a
flashlight should be like michael jordan
flashes are going off the whole time so
they get to the point where they're
putting everybody on the jumbotron right
right
so they start on the i'm i'm most center
court
just just me someone i forget who is
there from the knicks
and and um they start from the long end
right
so so what happens is the kid you see
the movie baby driver
of course i've seen babies see that kid
right he goes
big he's a knicks gear big bro angle
endsworth is his name something i think
his name is angle and endsworth
by the way it just looks this is a
unique name i believe engel ellsworth
by the way just real quick lebron james
36 years old born december 30th 1984.
i was born august 26 1984 lebron james
is younger than me
so younger than you yeah yeah i i am
older than lebron james
our lives are a little different yeah i
am older happy to be here i am older
than
every single person in the nfl
even tom yes i am you're older than tom
i am
interested every single player in the
nfl i am older than you are older than
isn't that wild that is why and the
youngest player
i'm more than two times their age the
you can be
the youngest player in the nfl's father
easily today
the youngest player there is potential
the youngest player in the nfl
father younger than you that's correct
that's the very
very huge possibility yes i think i'm
like older than justin bieber's mom
right you could be justin bieber's mom i
could be his man and you not no
and and listen i don't know about but
you're not are you justin bieber's mom
no but i would have raised him with the
same amount of love i swear to you okay
you guys see the super bowl
yeah god bless either tom brady or or uh
you know or or patrick one but yeah 81
yeah radio brady won and then tom by the
way his name is ansel elgort
yeah tom brady by the way not only won
the super bowl uh
one mvp and then and then three days
later got
absolutely annihilated on avocado
tequila avocado martinis
and for me even if you are even if he is
your
rival even if tom brady is your rival
team if you don't like tom brady i think
there's something wrong with you because
it's like
the kid's a winner he's an absolute
winner
and he likes to drink and have a good
time at this point how can you hate him
i don't know how can you hate against
him i mean it's the one thing
with the pats right but to go and do
what he did this year it's almost like
you have to root for the guy
how do you not root for the guy you have
to root for this he's he's also the
oldest player in the nfl
i think there i think a fact about him
is too i don't think he's ever eaten a
strawberry
it says here he does says here he
doesn't drink coffee yet
he doesn't even drink coffee i don't
think he's ever physical now how do you
know that
i thought i saw an interview say that
he's never had a strawberry in his life
i've never had a cinnabon
you've never had a cinnabon no remember
i never had one yeah
the thing is though we were talking
about this because last week you said
something about it yeah and
i don't want to wait i don't want to
deviate no no no i don't want i i don't
want to deviate but let me just
let me just bring up let me just bring
up
the the just uh you know an edited text
of
you said to me we were talking you and i
were gonna bring up the text again
i had said to you yes cause i'm always
on my fitness pal counting cows
yeah we're talking about stuff and then
i said out of nowhere i said do you
believe this sal
i just went on my fitness pal app
because i ordered cinnabons and carvel
for my family
i said it's one cinnabon is 800 calories
gangbusters 800 calories i said i'm not
going to log it into my fitness pal
because if i don't log it in it doesn't
count correct
so so you said you said to me
and i sent you a picture of them and you
said wow you said i thought they were
even more than that i've never had one
i think sometime i think someone gave me
a bite once but can't even confirm i've
certainly never bought one that'd be
impossible
yes and i said sal what do you mean
that'd be
impossible he goes and then and then
and then he goes uh and then oh then we
said uh uh
uh some voice notes and then i said no
you were telling me that we should
since you haven't had a pork chop and i
haven't had a you were freaked out that
i hadn't had a cinnamon i
i couldn't it would you freaked out more
than i freaked out and you didn't see
the godfather right you didn't have a
workshop
i couldn't believe when you said that in
a cinnabun yeah and now keep in mind
we are in new york city we we we it's
okay to tell them we live in
in new york city yeah which is probably
the most famous city in the whole world
sure i say you i say we should on the
next episode
and dubuque i say on the end dubuque
shout out to buick
minnesota mm-hmm okay uh iowa
iowa dubuque iowa it's dubuque iowa yeah
sorry yeah sorry
it's yeah it's you're right it's dubuque
iowa i feel stupid yeah it's um
it's yeah sheboygan wisconsin sheboygan
um
um so i say to you on the next episode
of hey babe
i should eat a pork chop and pork chop
and you should eat a cinnabon yeah and
you say
100 let's do that hopefully we can get a
cinnabon somehow
and that's when i threw my phone at the
wall i
said somehow we live in new york city
and then i proceeded to google locations
of of of knowing
where your home address is knowing my
own mattress and i found at
anywhere you look within under a mile
there's a cinnabon
somewhere and you and then cause you
said because you said to me yeah
you said to me there's no way there's a
cinnabon and you said you
you think you can only get it in a mall
i thought you could only get them in the
mall no that's the only
time i've ever seen them yeah or an
airport or something maybe no
you can get cinnabons at carvels and you
didn't know that
they didn't know that but the fact you
said yeah because you were saying like i
guess if we have to go through tsa and
do all that we could do that for the bit
to go to the airport and get the
cinnabon and i'm like no sal we don't
have to do any of that
you can literally want to find out i
literally i was howling
laughing at my phone i thought i needed
to book passage
yeah in order to get a cinnabon access
yeah you were like oh do we also have to
we have to go you're like you know like
with covert i can't really be going into
the mall right now
and i'm like what is he talking about we
could just go get a cinnabon
i didn't realize that they like you can
get a cinnabon like in your neighborhood
yeah 100 right in your neighborhood yeah
yeah so i
yeah so that's so so that's what we're
talking about so there's brick and
mortar
oh no no no they just is there a
cinnabon like a cinnabon store
or is it just like cinnabon people carry
sit up unlike carvel
there's a hundred percent fresh ice
cream
fresh do you know that carl theme song
hey
ice cream hey babe
no oh yeah so we can do we'll do i'll
try a cinnabon
this is what we're going to do i'm going
to try a cinnabon it's just am i saying
it right is it cinnabon
cinnabon it's cinnabon but they say they
spell it's b-o-n like cinnabon
it's c-i-n-n-a-b-o-n-c in a bun
but why so doesn't that make you want to
say cinnamon cinnabon
it does make me wait how do you spell
cinnamon c-i-n-n-a-m-o-n
oh it's m-o-n and it's b-o-n so we say
cinnamon so it should be cinnabon
cinnamon from jamaica yeah
cinnabon cinnabon cinnamon
cinnabit yeah it should say cinnabon
you're right but they put on the b-o-n
because i think they're trying to be
you know a little bit more i guess
upscale but but a cinnabon
cinnabon why don't they call it a cinema
oh because
cinnabun is what it really is they're
they're they're right they're changing
it they're stylizing it the cinnabon
right because it's has cinnamon
or no i would say yes if i had to guess
i would say yes that the reason why it's
called the cinnabon is because they've
just changed the b
to an m you're throwing bees at me babe
let me ask you this okay yeah
you've had a cinnabon i've had a
cinnabon i've had multiple cinnabons so
is the main ingredient
cinnamon the main ingredient for
cinnabon cinnamon in it cinnamon
cinnamon cinnamon cinnamon we have we
talked about this before i feel like
i've talked about this before
no no not with me are you serious
cinnamon
cinnamon is the main ingredient in a
cinnabon
are you reading this no no no i'm not
i'm i'm genuinely i'm coming from memory
would you say the star
of the cinnabon is the icing
or the cinnamon i would say
i would say that the star
of the cinnabon is
the sheer size of it is it the dough
it's the i would say this
the star of it you i would say this you
absolutely
cannot make a cinnabon without cinnamon
okay but you can make it without dough
or icing but you need cinnamon
to make a cinnabon well you can make it
without icing but how can you make a
cinnabon without
dough then it's just a bun
with no cinnamon but the bond is a bun
and the bun is dough
well oh listen just for fun
just for fun yeah we can try to explore
ideas of how you can make a cinnabon
without cinnamon juan do you want to do
that well listen i'm only one man
so yeah well we'll see if we can see if
we can
yeah did i ever tell you about the time
i was on the run
no yeah i was on the run and what
happened
i was in the sun eating a cinnabon and
it i wanted some more cinnamon
so then i started to run was that the
day you went to see uh tron
yes that's the way what's she tron and
the reason why i have a thing over my
eyes right now is because i
i got a squirt of lemon in it and it's
stinging
let's stay on a sting on okay yeah
and how far you think we could take this
i think the sky's the limit hon yeah i
think we could keep going or we could
get
right on right on i um
at what point do we start having people
join the fun or are they
getting i think we're just about there
and i'm
ready to officially say this bit is done
this is this is done this is done
this is the app the opposite of fun but
we had a nice run
it was a nice run and we did what we can
but
honestly i'm sweating bullets uh yeah
this is a bomb this is a bomb this is
now a full bomb
a bomb but you know what a cinnabon this
is a cinnabon this is a
yeah this is what they call in in in the
word comedy world
this is a cinnabon at this point we had
them
right we had them they were on board you
had them and then we lo we had them and
then we lost them but it doesn't matter
when do you guys think the cinnamon bun
was invented
the cinnamon bun was invented i'll tell
you what it is right now homeless pimp
the cinnamon bun was invented
in 1982 in fredericksburg mississippi
by a man named uh by a man named john
chester what is the answer
wow 17th century 17th century
yeasty bread have long been produced
i can't i don't have my glasses it
wasn't until a perfect storm of sugar
carbs and spice conversion the 17th
century that the cinnamon bun
as we know today was born but when was
cinnabon
the store made so it's not a cinnabon
it's a cinnamon bun
but one thing you have to understand is
back in the day sweets
like that like the sweets that like king
henry the eighth used to eat or
marie antoinette they weren't sweet like
we know it today like
sugar was a different thing like i went
to a place once
i forgot exactly where it was where they
had cakes and food that tasted and were
cooked
exactly the way they were in in uh like
back in the day in like medieval times
and it's even the cakes are disgusting
disgusting and but not discussing them
but disgusting because of how
much sugar how addictive we are to sugar
yeah we it's like
it's like the you it's i don't want to
say it's inedible it's not inedible
you could still taste like that things
are sweeter but they didn't have
sugar like we had it back then right
right and you know
so what when was cinnabun invented do we
know pimp
december 4th 1985 i said 1982.
wow that's a very specific day that it
was invented well
i mean the cinnabon first door opened
what an idea by the way for a
for a business so let me get this
straight then hold on
i'm doing some quick math but no top so
then tom brady is older than the
cinnabon
tom brady yeah tom brady's older than
cinnabon yeah
so the cinema could play in the nfl oh
the thousand the cinnabon should
the cinnabon could be retiring from the
nfl at any moment
we'd love by the way i've never heard
anyone say anything bad about a cinnabon
but i have heard people say like like if
they try to
eat because it's not different sizes
this is one monstrosity
well no because cinnabons evolved in
over the last few years they now have
mini cinnabons they have big cinnabons
they have different types of flavors
let me ask you this is there a cinnabon
cereal there's got to be there is
pimp with nope if not i want 10's pimp
smoke
yeah they got it we got it ready there's
a sin upon cereal there's a cinnabon
cereal
oh so they really branched out there's a
cinnabon cream of wheat
yeah i mean i don't know who's
necessarily going
ape [ __ ] for the cinnabon cream of wheat
scale of one to ten
how much do you like a cinnabon okay
so not counting how many calories it has
and not thinking about the devastation
it would do to my tits
i would say cena i would say devastation
i say
i mean the more the merrier the more the
merrier yeah yeah i would say cinnabon i
like a cinnabon a ten
i think it actually is here are the two
are the top desserts in my opinion
i would put cinnabon a freshly piping
hot cinnabon
yeah at number one first
of all desserts number two tiramisu
and number three oreo cookies wow
what about you i don't have it at the
ready
it's well i've seen you're a chocolate
guy cookies
cook but that's very broad yeah i love
cookies i love chocolate
sure sure i'm not a big candy guy
i think a brownie is is up there a
freshly baked brownie yeah
freshly baked brownie is very very good
but
all right i gotta just get there i gotta
make you a pork chop i'll have a
cinnabon
yeah and uh that's what we gotta try it
live on the first time
and goat cheese i never if we could get
a goat in here and milk it i've never
had i've never had goat milk or goat
cheese if we can
would you mind what we should do is just
make a short list maybe five things each
that we've never had
right and we'll do we'll do a taste
testing of them all right here
guys what i'm saying live on the show
live on the show so
enzo um what's his name elso enzo algar
and egg and algorithm and dog or baby
let's just call him baby drive a bd
i mean no disrespect to him at all i
just it's a unique name and i don't want
to get it wrong
so this guy she everyone cheers they
slide the camera down
fat joe your boy big time love fat joe
joey crack
fat show's there he's in jordan's he's
he's all
flied out the place goes wild it's
fascinating new york favorite show
right new york zone god bless him right
god bless fat joke
goes scans matthew broderick
place goes ape [ __ ] he's another new
yorker
ferris buells right and of course
everything else he did which was amazing
as well
uh because he has had a long illustrious
career absolutely okay he brought
slides to a little bit of a matthew
broderick's son
i don't know the jumbotron i think he
was kind of in there with him
good kid waved i think everyone cheated
maybe he didn't but i was sitting but
you know he
did he did and um and uh
and then i'm like a little nervous i
don't really want to go up on the
jumbotron
right um and uh i'm like oh
you know and then uh everyone's you know
looking because they see who's there
right and then yelling and this and that
and then then all of a sudden
lights off they never come to me
they did matthew rodrick's son
and everyone i was the last one and it's
like and then everyone said everyone
like just yelling at me and everything
like so embarrassing but by the and by
that time had you and the impractical
jokers already sold out madison square
gardener already done that show
yeah i already sold it out
and then they're like thank you yeah and
i was like all right and i actually felt
relief
but then i got the residual everyone
being like yeah yeah you got
punk i don't know guys now you know
madison square garden just opened um for
ten percent
ten percent uh tickets really you get in
there
all tickets ten percent i genuinely
yeah i know i genuinely emailed my agent
and i said hey
you know what are the chances here yeah
that i could get in at madison square
garden because i think in new york city
ten percent of what's the master garden
max capacity uh like probably
eight eighteen thousand ten thousand
there's no
depends on the setup i said could we do
could we convince them and hey maybe i
can
outside chance in my home city sell 1800
tickets i could
like i could like because nobody that's
awesome i thought you would say could
you be one of the people sitting
courtside no because because the big
acts can't do it like you got you know
an act that's all that msg is not going
to do it for 1800 people but i certainly
would
and i could say i sold that man i said i
could i saw that master's regarding it
i could technically say that and and my
agent 20
27. my agent put in an ask yeah he put
it in asked he mastered his
square guard and he did yeah he did he
just he just said and they simp he said
he said they simply wrote back one word
no
that's what it was and he said you know
you know what i was thinking about the
other day
how how could i know and what i wish you
would see more of i
love ray j brandi's brother oh of course
i love this guy i love i love him
i know his songs yeah i love his music i
love some of the videos he's been in
i love ray j and i just wish i heard
more about him but i haven't seen
anything
from ray j lately have you are you nuts
are you nutso in your head
yes he has his own headphones icons
babies
ray cards are from rachel you don't know
nothing about that i love writing they
have wireless headphones
and they they they they hook up to
bluetooth nice and easy they got six
hours of play time
yeah yeah you do know raycon of course i
know ray cut i had them in my ears
yesterday you had a pair of recons in
your ear yesterday and didn't know that
they were owned by ray j
and today you brought up ray j on your
own
i literally this morning had my raycon
headphones
was listening to brandy sitting up in my
room sitting here thinking about you
but the reason why i was listening that
song is because i want to feel closer to
ray j and i didn't realize
ray j is actually inside of me you ray j
was inside of you like many of
you know ray j was inside your ears yes
like
no no i'm saying like usually he's
inside your ears because of the sonic
right
the sonicness of it but now he's
physically inside you he was rayjay was
physically inside of me
through rake raycon headphones and i and
all you have to do if you want to get
ray j inside
no strings attached no strings attached
literally
by raycon.com hey babe the website is
by byu raycon r-a-y-c-o-n
dot-com slash hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e get
ray j
inside you so sal i've really the last
like couple of weeks
i've been really having like a rock-hard
penis for most of the day
interesting because i've been using
bluetooth i've been using because i had
those problems when i
i couldn't get my penis up and nothing
i'd do it just my dick would it just
wouldn't go up but now i've been going
to bluechew.com and i put in the promo
code hey babe
and i've been getting it for free no
that's
not nothing in this life is free well
you get five dollars off
shipping no that's not true at all you
spend five dollars for shipping
and you get it for free you spend five
dollars i was setting you up to be like
no there is things in life that you get
for free
and then i thought you were gonna hit
them with the great deal that we have
for them but
we floundered and we're not going to
edit this out because we're men of the
people because women are the people and
i'm proud to stand by my erection
and if you just go to bluetooth.com
promo code hey babe yes
then what exactly you're going to do you
try it for free you you get your first
shipment free
and and then you just pay five beans for
the shipping
that's it so you're paying for the
shipping you're getting the product for
free you can't beat that you can't beat
think about the the ads we do 10 off 20
off
no this is that the other this is free
free promo code hey babe pay five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com that's it right
this coming monday i have wild news
if you go to yopeanut.com that's y
o p e a n u t dot com
guess what you're gonna find new no
presh saratoga peanut butter flavors you
can go get the no
press pack it's two eight ounce jars
one butterscotch peanut butter blend one
white chocolate almond butter with maine
blueberry shout out maine
that's the hey babe and taste buds
podcast in a pack of saratoga peanut
butter
you made our dreams come true thank you
to the fans this monday
it's live yopeanut.com take a photo
with the peanut butter that you buy with
the no press pack with a hey babe and
taste buds take a picture with it
all the proceeds are going to a child
abuse charity
so it's really awesome that go help
those kids that are in need
yopeanut.com we're excited i cannot
believe we got our own peanut butter
flavor i can't wait to smear it on my
nipples
so so uh wait what is this why is sal's
face up on what's going on
you got cell's face up on time square
right now so my face isn't right now on
a billboard on time square did i tell
you about this
no what's going on for the television
show they are renaming me
uh prince herb as you know her herb is
like you know like a corn ball like we
grew up here so it's like calling
somebody hurts your kids who made her
yeah
yeah so what they did was they
got me uh in times square and they
turned me around and i looked up
and it's the biggest billboard in times
square it's the one it's the entire
building underneath where the ball drops
and he just popped up i was like what is
that and they're like oh
it says now introducing newest cast
member prince herb
they changed the credits of the show to
prince herb in the credits
in the end in the beginning when i come
out on screen
instead of salad says prince they're
only going to refer to me as princess
for the rest of the season
and then in the billboard these two huge
diamond or cubic zirconia
studs it's animated and it falls down
and clicks onto my ears and i'm like yo
what's up with those
things like yeah now also right this
second we're putting cubic zirconia
studs in your ears and you're going to
have those in every scene for the rest
of the entire season too
and then they tell me we're going on
seth myers tonight and
you're going to be known as prince herb
on all media outlets interviews late
night daytime talk show they went on
kelly clarkson's show
they called me prince herb seth mars is
like uh please welcome my guest
sal joe marin i mean huge omar and
prince herb
wait a second so did you physically go
into the seth meyer studio and do this
it was a zoom because
because of the team but like but no yeah
like i i i can only go on stage now as
as prince herb and i pierced my freaking
ears yesterday
your ears are pierced right yeah so they
took studs out
because they were so big that they said
that if i if i have them in for a couple
days before we shoot again
it'll keep the wound open pretty big so
what they did was they put in these
little
pieces so the hole doesn't close up but
then when i go back on set every single
day for the rest of the year
i had to every single scene every single
day i film for the rest of the year i
have to wear double cubic zirconia
huge like three carat studs that
so that was a billboard yes it was
actually it actually was
yeah i was like i i know kids do it and
i know like people do it and everything
but i i was like it's gonna hurt a
little bit and they did my left ear
first it's a phenomenon he told me about
the left ear i was like ow okay right
you felt it it was sharp it was one
second it was done right and it was like
a little bit like tingly but then it
went away
so i was expecting the same for the
right ear the right ear hurt like 10
times more
for some reason i don't know if it's
right here left here but i don't know if
the guy just botched it but he was great
but something was different like the
pain threshold or the right ear was like
10 times worse
interesting yeah so that's now a
billboard in times square
of my face just my face to give you a
little perspective of how big that is
they said like most of my head is just
the head part like this
is 86 feet 86 so that's how big it is i
and this did this someone sent me an
aerial view from like like it's like a
it's called like live earth or something
the other yeah look at that
that's where you see it from all the way
down the block and from and how long
will that be up of your face in times
square
it was up for like the first hour full
while we filmed and now it's just like
intermittent it comes up
wow dude and look at me that's a live
feed see the cars driving but this is
live right now your face is up there in
times square what would you do if
somebody was able to somehow get the
devil ears and make a mustache on you
somehow you know like how they would do
in the subway i would just live my life
the same
nothing would change nothing for me
nothing would change did i ever tell you
about the time i
i tried to get my tongue pierced once no
on my 16th birthday you thought it was
because it was you did it because it was
hip
i did it because i was hip it was all my
friends did it it was my birthday party
that night where i was supposed to
my mom had like a big party yeah to like
eat like all my friends are coming over
chicken fingers all that stuff and i was
thinking like how am i going to eat my
food with a swollen tongue because all
my friends had to swollen
hell no everybody gets their tongue
pierced you have to
right three guys three three of my
friends go get their tongue pierced i'm
going up next
i sit down i'm in the chair the guy's
got you know the gloves or whatever
go stick out your tongue i go like this
he goes your tongue's too short i can't
pierce it thank god
yeah because he goes he goes and then
he goes like this he goes go like that
he goes now really stick it out and i
went
he goes stick it out as far as you can
so i went he goes your tongue's too
short i can't pierce it
i said is that a common thing do most
people have short tongues he goes no i
can usually pierce 99 percent of
people's tongues
i said you're telling me you have an
abnormally you're telling me you can't
pierce my tongue and he goes let me see
it one more time
and i go like daddy goes it's not your
real tongue
[Laughter]
i swear to god and i said you're so
lucky dude that i couldn't appear
that's probably i don't that's one thing
i don't get that's p
that seems like the most painful thing
ever right and then like what
and then what happens you just have a
piece of metal swirling around your
mouth
at all times i you know i
i don't know is that okay how is that
fun i don't know
like my friends who did it who got it
all
like have them taken out now because i
don't think you can be in your mid 30s
with the tongue ring anymore
i mean you could do whatever you want
but yeah my friend dom
uh d bartolomeo actually chef dom from
domenico shout out the minute goes out
in l.a
order your food from him go to his
independence is one of
i mean that's a doozy of a last name
yeah and it's it's it's almost like two
or three last names put together in one
last name and it's it's a classic name
and that keeps going
i have a new i have a child on the way
july 4th now one of the names
in the running is deeper tolerance would
be amazing i mean that's it that's
definitely
stefan that's a german kid he could have
like 11 nicknames
d but imagine you what's your name d
battalion male
1 it's like yeah that sounds like a
football player name but stephen
tollemail deepa tell him
yeah david talameo is it's it's a
fascinating it's it divital email says i
know how to make a good sauce
right and he does domenico's right yeah
so i told this report this is the guy
that we actually
we we've we made believe that we were
running out on the check at the diner
did i tell you that story no
i never told you that story no running
out on the check on the diner
no oh god all right well anyway all
right so mike you gotta do it okay
so this my friend in high school he was
like oh one day he comes to us and he
goes oh dude
i'm gonna get my belly button pierced
and we were like oh yeah that's a fun
thing for a guy oh like
like like i knew people were doing it
but it was like all females as far as i
knew
and then i just didn't really question i
was like oh i guess both people are
doing it like both sexes are doing it
like it's just a thing like a tongue or
an eyebrow or a nose right
and he went and got his belly button
pierced and had a dangly jewelry hanging
off of it
he was like a guitarist in like a but
not ironically like this he's just it
was decision he made
he wasn't like a fashion guy he was like
a regular guy but he decided i don't
know if he thought it was going to
be very appealing to people it wasn't a
goof he was like i want to get my belly
button
he was like oh dude i'm getting my belly
button pierced like you know how you do
that in high school like i'm getting a
tattoo
right and and i was like oh and i was
like oh i guess everyone's doing i guess
it's just like anything else
right then he did it and then like
months
went by and i never saw another male
with the best belly button and we all
were like hey
i think you might have thought everybody
was doing that but the guys aren't
really doing that not that you can't do
it
right but especially you you're not very
fashion forward
and so maybe it's time you take it out
right yeah we had to level with him
and he finally took it out i don't
remember if he took it out then but he
doesn't have it now
he doesn't and and if you see him now
it's hysterical that he had
it's such an ill-conceived thing right
now looking back that he got his belly
button pierced
like that i mean you know you got to
look like bruno
yeah you don't get it he did not look
like bruno let me ask you this
what do you think for a guy is a crazier
thing to do get a belly button ring or a
lower back tattoo
oh man i'd say maybe the tat because the
tats perm
perm yeah the belly button ring you can
just take out and also depends did this
guy have an indie or an audi
uh cause if you add an audi maybe he's
just looking to take
you know focus away from his belly
button i don't remember his
his exact navel i once was playing
basketball with the guy
like literally i saw this happen and he
was a big tall guy
and he went up for a dunk and he could
you know could easily dunk the
basketball and it was like uh you know
like um
the chain nets like in a park a lot of
parks don't have the chain nets
but this park had chain nets yes a few
years ago and he went up to dunk
and his ring finger got stuck in the
chain nut and i wa and he ripped his
finger off
you watched it happen finger was
his down with the wedding ring on was
dangling in the chains
oh like it was an isis video oh my god
yep it was the most disgusting thing
i've ever seen in my life and that's why
those things are dangerous that's why
those things are dangerous
and then then what happens that he like
was like uh he's screaming in pain his
finger was
it was like in a movie he was shooting
like like sprouting
uh spouting blood sprouting like it's an
alfalfa sprout like it's a seven grain
my mouth is white old sprouting
sprouting blood oh i want ezekiel bread
right now you know what i could really
go for right now i have a decorated tuna
fish on an ezekiel bread
i would love a tuna melt on his ears
both of those things i could do ezekiel
english muffins
uh no i mean don't be an [ __ ] but i
have i have english muffin
and i have ezekiel and you could put one
english muffin and one decal together
and maybe see what you get i mean that's
what i want i want a tuna i mean for you
because cause
because i won't go downstairs and make
you a tuna sandwich half ezekiel have
english month because i will
i i mean i mean test my friendship
i next episode that's what you're going
to be chewing on
that's it that's going to be the next
episode ezekiel bread
ezekiel and schmuffle with tuna i mean
yeah i mean okay so remember the other
day i told you i said i'm sick and tired
of going to the grocery store i'm not
doing anymore there's covert there's
lines i don't want to do it anymore yeah
you were screaming at me
and i said can there be at least one
place that gives me
22 or more fresh recipes and ingredients
it was specific
but i thought it was odd but yeah you
said that well i found it
hello fresh i went to hellofresh.com you
ready for what i did oh i know about
hellofresh you know about hellofresh
what did you do i went to i couldn't
believe what this was was happening i go
to hellofresh.com
on a whim i put in the promo code hey
babe 10.
just out of nowhere i said just try
something you know so i go hey babe 10
promo code they gave me 10 free meals
but you paid for shipping i didn't pay
for shipping get out of here i checked
my credit card bill i called i said
there's been fraudulent activity there's
no nobody even charged me for shipping i
got 10 hello fresh meals in here by
using the promo code hey babe
who's the ceo of hello fresh crazy eddie
that's insane it's santa claus
what are what are even the options for
the food i did look it up okay there's
there's carb smart okay locale
pescatarian vegetarian everything you
want
and it's basically uh they they they
package
fresh produce from from local farmers
from local farmers i mean what else do
you want
they're even following the trends here
yeah and you know what they do they
pre-package the portions and the
ingredients so you're not over buying i
saw that you have to go to
these big box stores and buy enough for
a month and then it goes away you're
spending too much on your wallet it's
too much waste for the environment
i don't need it this is helping out i
don't need it at all and and and these
little packages they come
and i cook them i've learned finally
learned how to cook i feel safe because
getting delivered right to my door
and i'm telling you i'm telling you i
literally was sitting down it was like
god himself was speaking to me or
herself or they self would speak to me
and they said do me a favor chris
go to hellofresh.com put in the promo
code
hey babe 10. and watch your dreams come
true
and they did i got 10 free meals
including free shipping that's a lot
that's a lot of meals if you eat three
meals a day that's like
three meals point one day worth the food
for
no for no no cost no cost at all
i don't understand how i don't
understand the business model that's not
for us to decide that's not for us go to
hellofresh.com
hey babe10 use code heybabe10 for 10
free meals including free shipping yeah
america's number one meal kit what do
you think
trick question i don't think
more than 50 million men in the united
states you know what they suffer from
i'm gonna give you the initials mpb
m m p b
yep michael peanut butter
nope okay male pattern baldness okay
same
male pattern baldness and guess what
yeah there's actually
what when i when i this morning i woke
up
first thing i said to my mother my
mother stepped over first thing i said
to her i said mom there's got to be at
least five
fda recommended products for male
pattern baldness
she said i would say more than that
honey guess what only two
there are only two fda approved
medications that prevent hair loss you
know what one of them is
you know keeps keeps
they don't no that's not the medication
keeps offers
both of the two fda approved medications
yeah you ruined the whole thing
oh i'm sorry no no we're going to keep
going you're going to
keep this in we're going to keep this in
okay yeah
well keeps convenient virtual doctor
consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home you don't have
to leave your home
guess what what you know what whenever
this episode comes out
yeah it's probably going to come out
somewhere soon
around easter time yeah guess what baby
you're not getting peeps this year
you're getting keeps that's what you get
what you got to do all you got to do if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss now
all you got to do is go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash hey babe
to receive your to receive your first
month of treatment
for free what is it sal tim tell him
again that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey
babe
to get your first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash hey babe
do you know anything about ezekiel bread
uh nothing but the name
it's flourless it was the same allegedly
called ezekiel bread because it's the
same bread
they used at jesus's time they made it
like jesus allegedly jesus would have
eaten ezekiel bread
what does that mean oh you mean the
timing wise the timing was so kind of
how
when i said like they would make things
like you know like sweets and all that
stuff
as they did like in medieval times
ezekiel bread allegedly is made
as it would have been in jesus's time so
i don't know if they make it from stone
and purify it in the river i don't know
what they do
what did they do for like meals back
then
i know they multiplied fish and they
pounded wine but like you'd have to
are there sandwiches no sam no come on
sandwiches was invented by earl sandwich
oh right no that's that's true he was it
was the sandwich was invented on by the
earl of sandwich
oh people that by the way people back in
jesus time ate a mostly plant-based
clean diet they were keto friendly
in that region of the world lentils
whole grains fruits vegetables dates
nuts and fish
were all quite popular for snacks some
even ate grasshoppers and crickets oh so
they were doing what's that the caveman
the paleo paleo they were paleo kids
that's why jesus had abs what do you
want to know what do you want it was
ripped
um um yes so i yeah i really right now i
said on the last podcast
because i had to tune him out from a
place and now i really just want to tune
him out on ezekiel because i'm trying i
only have 700 calories left for the day
so it gets dicey because it's only three
o'clock in the afternoon uh yeah you
went hard with the calories early on
but i went hard but you know what i had
is my girlfriend made oatmeal
pancakes so it was literally she made
pancakes but it was oatmeal banana
it was two cups of oatmeal banana honey
and i think she put dark chocolate chips
in it but it was a pancake
but it was all oatmeal it wasn't any
pancake mix but that hit me for 700 cows
wow that sounds like a really nice um
early afternoon
yeah yeah yeah yeah why not i mean i got
up at 6 a.m i was walking out it's a
snow day here again in new york
another time what do you want literally
every time we do this podcast it's
snowing
outside and uh it's another snow day for
my daughter um so we were
woken up at 6 a.m and she opened the
front door which she does now got a
thing of snow and hit me in the face
with it so that's what it was
yeah she's the best um so
where are we at because i have the i
have this did you ever run out on a bill
did you ever run out of that i never ran
out on a bill still to this day never
ran out on a bill
but and i never told you about the time
we ran out on a bill no okay is this
with dominic
uh yeah yeah what's that last name again
tyler mayo d patala mayo yeah do i told
the man should we get
i want to get a t-shirt says deepa
tolomeo shout out tom yeah so
so we go to we go to a diner here on
satellite i think it was the golden dove
golden dove on richmond do you know are
you named for a diner no
the only diner i know on on on staten
island
not only they have great food this diner
i've eaten there many times
i've done a comedy show there and i also
had my daughter's confirmation after
party there the colony
colonnade's the king the number one but
that's great but
so many times i mean i had my daughter's
baptism there dude
i have we've had a family after the wake
there yeah colony
it's the place and then and then the
back of it became the looney bin comedy
club
i didn't know that yes when i was little
before they did the whole refurbished my
dad used to take me there for breakfast
and we used to sit at the bar and i used
to love it because i would order those
little boxes of cereal yeah but like as
a kid those little boxes of cereals like
it's so fun
it's so funny yeah it's like i'm gonna
have a whole box my grandfather when i
would open up those little boxes he
wouldn't let me pour it into a bowl
because he was like no the way they have
the box set up is you you make the box
you make this you pour the milk into the
box and you eat it out of the box
but that's late in the game that's when
they made the bowl packaging
yes i had the mini cardboard they just
look like
like cereal boxes for smurfs they were
just little
little boxes and that's why for kids it
was like it was amazing right yeah
remember dunkaroos
by the way yeah how great are they gone
i think dunkaroos are gone or they're
just making a comeback now
is basically you it's a cookie that you
dunk the chocolate in right or the icing
yeah it's pretty much you got to do the
work they're still out 90s nostalgia
dunkaroos great name
dunker i actually add a roux to a lot of
when i speak and i don't know how i
don't know how it started or anything so
like what's it exactly like can i have a
coffee rule or
i'll say like um uh
um you know what i can't think of it
[Laughter]
no like i'll be like uh you wanna have a
little luncharoo
a little lunchroom something like that
like where it fits but i i say it
often now that you said dunkaroo and i'm
like no one why do i say that
right i i guess it's just me being like
silly goose you gotta think about two
marketing and stuff like that too
because
she was so popular in the 90s and still
is to this day why didn't they ever
collaborate
with rupaul and have a dunker rupaul and
and you have rupaul's
halloween great halloween costume
combined
duncan rupaul oh that's pretty cool
it's a giant graham cracker kangaroo
drag queen
that's what i want to do
might also be a new mascot duncan rupaul
new mascot along with all the other ones
so you're in the diner with with uh dom
massachusetts yeah so i'm gonna yeah
uh me it's me bobby cannavale what's the
last name again the dipatolomayo
divatollah okay
so um so my friend drives and he drives
and he has his toyota supra
he was such like a rocker he had the
license plate that was a metal chain
around it okay right and so um
it's four of us and my friend goes to
someone floats the idea of walking out
on a check
never do but by the way recent study
claims one out of 20 people have dined
and dashed
so really it's one out of 20 so it's a
lot of people have done it five percent
of people have
skipped a bill five percent of people no
you have to do it
you ever skip a bill only when the
service was so so so terrible you walked
out on bed service
oh no like you were like you didn't skip
on a bill you were like
i don't want this meal the food sucked
and then the waiter never came back so i
just got up and left
okay and you just left it there like
that it wasn't you didn't feel like you
were running from a bill
i didn't gain anything but they lost
something right that's true so you
technically ran for it but it wasn't
like
this was great now let's not pay that's
not really nice
have you ever done it uh no i i'm one of
those guys
even if you give me a horrible haircut
or the food sucks i'll still just pay
full price and tip
yeah i just always do that i i ate
yesterday
i i went to get something to eat and it
was terrible and i was in the middle
of telling the person i was with how
terrible it was and the waitress came
over and goes how's everything gonna go
it's great thank you
am i gonna get this is the worst how did
the balls on this place right to charge
15.
and everything's great thank you so much
that's what i do because you know what
to do but the thing is though
when something like that like i think
that's healthier than complaining and
throwing a fit because it's like it's
just a part of your day it sucked
but it's like you got you things are
okay we went to this
like 2003 i was in miami uh touring with
uh a
comedy festival and we went to this
place called kiss steakhouse i have no
idea if it's still there right it was
one of these steakhouses that was
worried more about being trendy
than about being a steakhouse maybe and
i went with the guys we were on tour and
i went with the guys
in 2003 yeah yeah not on yeah we want we
toured as like a sketch comedy troupe
and we were in the um miami improv
festival that year right
so we go and uh we're we were like oh
this will be a big night out you know we
have a lot of money so one i will like
we'll do a steakhouse one night
save your duckets right so we get there
and we order it
and we are so excited there's big velvet
chairs
they look like like king chairs that
we're sitting in and it's like it's all
like
there's big lips everywhere it's like
very like trendy miami
and we order like oh my god we order
like 40 dollars like you know and then
the guy brings it over
and it's tough and cold like immediately
like on the as soon as they drop them we
start eating everyone looks
like slowly looks up and it's like this
is is this not good right and everyone's
like no it's not good yeah and i
i'll never forget it because we said um
we go we go my friend's like my friend
goes like this it was it was my friend
gideon i think he goes
he goes this is cold and disgusting
as he disgusting was coming out of his
mouth our waiter came over and went
as he was still saying they were
disgusting he goes gentlemen everything
hot and delicious
he said the two opposite words
and we all go yes he walked away and we
started crying
because we're like you were saying the
words cold and disgusting he said hot
and delicious
it is thank you so much oh my god
disgusting cold and disgusting but he's
like
gentlemen everything hot and delicious
we say that that's one of those things
that we never stopped saying
yeah so like 18 years later i have i
said tim gentlemen my friend would go
everything hot and delicious
did you just pay full price so full
price walked out of course never went
back
that's like i went to a wedding once and
literally we're eating the penny vodka
it was penny vodka which is like a
staple at any wedding in new york or
like an italian wedding always gonna
have penny vodka
we eat in the penny vodka and i turned
to the i forgot who i was with
forgot to whoever i was with says does
it taste like there's a cigarette
in the penny vodka and she goes yeah it
literally tastes like
somebody dropped a cigarette in the
penny vodka and then an older guy
was at our table and i said to him i
said sir what does your penny vodka
taste like
he goes it tastes like somebody dropped
the cigarette i swear so then he calls
over
the waiter he goes hey we all feel like
somebody dropped a cigarette in the
penny vodka because it tastes like if
somebody asked the penny vodka and the
waiter says i'm sure that's not it but
let me go check with the chef and of
course bring you out a full batch
of penny vodkas so 10 minutes go by he
comes out with a full batch of penny
vodkas let's say 10
he goes uh you know we're still like
sitting there whatever waiting
he takes all our plates away puts all
our plates down and then says you guys
are right the chef
said he accidentally dropped it somebody
dropped a cigarette in the penny box he
admitted to it he admitted to it
yeah but that's insane the reason why
i'm bringing that up is because
we i told the bride at the time i was
like somebody dropped
a cigarette in the penny vodka and they
didn't even complain because they were
just like oh are you guys okay
yeah but somebody had dropped had ashed
accidentally in the penny vodka
so the waiter just admitted it wow yeah
let me ask you this i was at a wedding
one time okay and the person
i i mean we were all assuming the reason
is uh and a little bit later
that the person didn't like the food
choices okay they ordered a pizza to the
wedding
and then like a full like just for them
they ordered a pizza for them oh you
mean somebody
as a guest yes wow and that's and then
they it was like it wasn't a large it
was like a small
but it was a pizza box and they they got
it and then they ate the pizza at their
table out of a pizza box
that's actually is that that's wrong on
them right a thousand percent
yeah that's wrong on them but it's so
ballsy if i was ever
getting married i would respect it
actually i'd respect it i'd be like wow
dude that was
like dominoes or i was thinking no it
was probably local like wherever it was
from
but that's what i was thinking if
because you said they took it in stride
that there was an ash in the penny
right so i was thinking like if if i saw
because i remember seeing that and i was
like i can't believe this
but i wonder if it was like my wedding
would i be like i'll let it go
but i would be i would be like why do
they is the food bad like why are they
getting
a pizza delivered right right yeah i i
couldn't even have the
there's a lot of things that people do
like i would never have the balls
even if i want i would maybe leave the
wedding early
yeah and say right like for example one
time you know
with with jasmine my girlfriend sorry
with jazz and my girlfriend now
we went i went to a wedding a good
friend of mine uh uh
wedding i thought i had a plus one
i just thought i had a plus one we drove
probably two hours to get to the wedding
oh yeah
we've all been there we go sit down you
know in the beginning with the cocktail
we go get a place cards there
there was no plus one it just says chris
stefano no guess let me let me take you
through let me let me guess
what you did go ahead they were
accommodating they put you another seat
and didn't make you feel out of place
and you you did your best with also
did you feel terrible or were they did
they handle it the right way because
what are you going to do it you can't
what are you going to do i'll tell you
what we did tell don't tell me that you
will like just go to jazz no
jazz we just just go i'll meet i'll find
you me and jasmine
turned around and we walked out of the
wedding didn't say goodbye to anyone i
left the wedding card gift
not even in a box because it wasn't out
yet i left it on the table
that had that said i i po wrote on the
outside of the envelope
chris destefano like you know so they
knew were you doing them a courtesy or
were you like
no plus one i'll leave that right there
no no no no you would like let me
try and do the right thing we were so
embarrassed that i was like you know
what
the only way to make this better is for
me to pay for mine and
jasmine's seat and then leave the only
thing i did take is they were giving out
as a i guess a wedding favor some type
of hot honey and jasmine said she could
use that on a type of chicken dish she
was making later on
later on in the week so we did take the
hot honey and we used that on some poyo
but but that way i literally that is
mortifying yeah we we
i never forget we went to a wendy's and
we we had some food and we ate in the
parking lot we drove back and
you know our daughter we were her mother
was babysitting our daughter and she was
like what happened at the wedding we
were like oh we actually jasmine wasn't
invited so we turned around and came
home
i i gotta be honest i probably would do
the same yeah i probably would do the
same because
it's too much of an imposition i mean
it's a miscommunication but you don't
want to cause
any strife or not a single issue on that
day for them
no right so i think you did that i think
you did the noble thing there
yeah that's a mortifying situation you
ever call someone by the wrong name
after like years of knowing them even um
i i've done that i've accidentally go
but like i've
i've done that we well this is something
that my buddy does to me all the time
to the point where now i i'll never
believe him if i ask someone's name but
like he's caught me a couple of dozen
times in my life
when i'm like oh what's the name and
he's like philip and i'm like philip and
they're like
uh and i'm like it's so much so
mortifying
yeah i i i because i call everybody
buddy or babe
i think like that's how i get away with
it because but normally like i won't
know
somebody's name i'm like hey what's up
buddy how you doing babe i'll always do
the thing where if i don't know your
name and let's say i'm with someone i
have to deduce i'm like oh this is
jasmine
and then they will always say their name
that's the way to get around it you
never
trick everybody knows you just have to
do that what about people call you i
don't correct
like when they mispronounce my last name
but like okay so like
someone like there's a there's a comic
who calls me soul
really yeah it's awful but he says
sometimes he says
sometimes he says saul but he says saul
as much as he says cell
and it's been years of knowing him and i
and i just i just don't say anything
because he's such a good
he's such a he's someone i look up to
someone i look up to though
and he calls you saul yeah i tell a
davidtale calls you
like he's one of my heroes so i'm just
like yeah i'm just tall so well you know
what he
came up to me once david tell yeah but
he's also called me sal no but
but he also you know dave you know dave
just does what he wants to do because he
said to me once i swear to god we're at
the comedy cellar he was sitting
always in the aisle where he was smoking
it uh outside right right outside the
off tree smoking a cigarette
and you know he knows me he's like oh
chris he's like what's up i'm like how
you doing man he goes
he goes let me ask you questions are you
one of those impractical jokers
and i said and i said no i said i'm not
one of them
he goes he go i said i know them and he
was like yeah he was like he was like i
thought you were one of those
impractical jokers for this whole time
and i'm like oh he goes i love that show
i was like i don't think you watch it
no i don't think because you know when
you can tell someone's like they know
the show because it's your face
but they don't really know it and they
then they make an assumption on what it
is
yeah and i'm like oh that's not what it
is so you kind of don't really know what
it is
is one of those guys who's like a new
york
or just an american comedy world comedy
legend
yeah he and and the way he is him and
colin quinn yeah
are like guys from that era that are
just so
cool and nice to like the younger
comedians coming up in the game
i had a cbs pilot in development uh
a sitcom in development and literally
when we were at the script writing stage
of it
somebody told somebody said something to
me about it and davidtell was there
maybe that somebody come in audition for
it stuff like that and dave attell heard
it and dave said to me he said
listen he said if you want he gave me
his email he wrote his email i'll never
forget he wrote his email on a gum
wrapper which i was like you couldn't
just send it to me would wrote in my
phone but david tells david
he wrote his email on a gum wrapper he
said here's my email
he said email me the script if you want
he said i'll
punch it up as best i can for you no
char
no nothing no name on the credit he's
like i just want to see
you know the young guys do well that's
amazing and then i i never emailed it to
him because
when we got it it was like already like
moving i should have emailed him the
show did not get picked up and i could
have just seen the other david tell
but i remember that i was like wow dude
like you
literally like most people would never
do that yeah he was just like whatever
it is i'll help you
yeah so i remember like one time we were
at a club together and then we were
going we had both had spots at the same
next club
right so we like i was like oh we shared
a cab
you know and it was like a good half
hour cab ride and like i never really
get one on one
half hour with a towel really yeah yeah
it's always people floating around and
stuff and like we were talking about
stuff
but like in my head i'm like uh this is
so cool i get to like talk to it
and then we get out and we go into the
cellar after that we go and
we're all talking and then he's like
yeah me and saul were in the
house it was like right after the half
hour cab ride
but like i've no it's not like he
doesn't know me i know him but it's like
it's like it's it's it's it's a 50 for
this shot if i'm getting south
but it's also it's also like yeah you
know what but that gives you character
it's like all right you know
you give him your saul yeah they stand
down though
i don't know why because soul is a name
in and of itself
my name was saul i think it's so funny
saul baron said yeah
i'm not saul yes saul rosenberg saul
rosenberg saul baron's
saul saul who used to be paul
in the bible and then the bible then
they changed his name no i think it was
saul and he changed his name to paul
yeah became one of the apostles i think
that's it it's all i haven't been going
on my resume
mort saul that's another person yeah i
don't know if it's saul
so we're in a diner right and dom goes
to the bathroom
and we go why don't we convince him that
we're gonna run out on the check and we
gotta go out one by one
right and and we'll see if he says yes
and we'll have him go out first
right and i don't know what how we
conceived that but to this day it was
one of the most brilliant things i've
ever heard so he comes back
and someone casually slips in the
conversation you guys wanna
dine and dash and he's like no do you
think we should do that we could do that
yeah i want to do that and everyone's
like yeah why not let's just do it
people do it
like if they catch us they catch us
we'll pay you know but but let's get to
rush let's
do it right he's like i don't know if
it's the right thing to do well i can do
it
yeah and he's like all right because he
drove right so like this is how it'll
have to happen
right in a couple of minutes you get up
you go get the car
pull the car right out front leave it
running right and then we'll leave
one by one i'll go last right you guys
get he had a toyota super it was a coupe
so they had to open and get in the back
that go you guys get in get in the back
door push the seat down right
when you see me coming from the door i
will run full speed i will dive into
that car take off
right he goes all right let's do it
let's do it and we're like yeah let's go
let's do it he goes oh my god we're
doing this
we're actually doing this you gotta
understand like well you can get in
trouble i don't know like
we don't really go around doing stuff
like that it's also wrong right there
was this whole rush involved right
he he gets up he like inconspicuously
walks out
you know belly button tattooed i mean uh
pierced
and he goes he gets his toyota super he
pulls it around we see it it was the old
car where the lights came out of the
hood
yeah yeah you see that lights go on the
hood he drove drives around we see it
running in the front with his
his his uh license plate chain around
just such a funny sight and then mike
think my girlfriend at the time was
there she leaves
and then i think or another one of our
friends chris he leaves
now of course i've paid the t right tim
and tipped and everything so thank you
very much i go to the front door
he sees me looking and i just kick the
door open i run i
jump down the steps and i hear him go he
just stops pushing like i jump into the
car
and he is i slam the door and he is
fishtailing
all over richmond avenue and we just
stopped screaming yes
and they're grabbing him from the back
like rubbing his shoulders and he's
punching the horn
and he's going he's swerving he's going
wake dead ahead
wait dad he's like yeah he's white
knuckling the steering wheel then we
just start
crying laughing and he blows like a red
light and he's like wait dad
and we're all left and he's like he goes
did we not
[Laughter]
like you [ __ ] we blew a red light and
fish though we almost all died like no
no we paid the full check you idiot you
idiot you stupid idiot anyway he
tattooed his belly button and
he's he he now runs domenico's food i
mean it goes foods
i i um i the only time
i've never
wait continue do it record it that's
what it is do it record it
and hashtag us right and by the way in
florida though if you're doing it in
florida just know dine and dash
penalties can be severe a theft of more
than 300
carry up to five years in prison and a
five thousand dollar fine but
if you do it and get caught we will
consider if the patron
uh when we start the paycheck if you get
enough patreon members paying your five
thousand dollar fine but we can't get
you out of prison that is true and you
know what we could do we could show some
of the best ones on the patreon that's
what we'll do you know what i mean yeah
we'll do that but listen so don't dine
and dash just
trick you one of your friends preferably
the one with the pierced belly button
yeah trick them into thinking you're
gonna do it and then do that and tape it
all
tape it all and then do it pimp has
brought up 40th grossest things found in
food and fast food somebody found a
condom in a big mac
so there you go and i haven't had a big
mac in
years and i don't know what i want more
right now a big mac or a tuna melt
it's one or the other a big mac i can't
get you oh no we can we can get in the
car in the blizzard and go get a big mac
oh no maybe a fun thing to do we could
do a frolic session they deliver
mcdonald's delivers now did you know
that no mcdonald's delivers yeah that'd
be the great
[ __ ] that'd be great that would be so
great if it was like
you had like it was ronald himself like
the delivery drivers were all in ronald
outfits yeah
that'd be so great who wins in a fight
ronald or the king or burger king yeah
like no a physical fight
like not like what food is better who's
who's who's
taking the other person out you think
like he's gonna get his big
shoe up the king's ass or you think the
king's the king for a reason and knows
he's been in a few battles the king's
the king for a reason but i think out of
just
i think ronald mcdonald is like the
joker almost yeah i was gonna say
winning the fight because he's chaotic
you know he's got the creepy look people
have done it by the way ronald mcdonald
and my mother have the same hair style
they have the same hair yeah and yours
and she has the king's robe i choose the
king's robe
um did you do people animate who would
win remember those remember that show on
a celebrity death match yes
yes i wonder if there was a celebrity
death match between those two celebrity
death match was awesome by any animators
out there if you could do a
a uh a battle of mcdon uh ronald
mcdonald vs burger king would greatly
appreciate it
yeah epic rap oh they've done a rap
battle i don't know ronald mcdonald
or the bird king rap oh rap battle guys
i know epic lloyd is a buddy of mine
long time yeah good guy whoa that was a
demonic uh
look at that yeah he's a little scary
ronald mcdonald could be a little scared
but make shout out mcdonald shout out
fast food
yeah dominoes for the domino's i
literally
oh ronald mcdonald king making out there
you go that's that's
that's the two of them through a hey
babe filter by the way shout out shout
out to gay community shout out our gay
fans and our and our trans fans
on our on our tick tock uh account of
our tupperware tick tock which has gone
viral thank you guys for
keep re-sharing that a lot of people are
coming out uh to their parents or
telling their parents they're gay or or
whatever
by using our tub aware video so if you
thank you guys for anyone who's done
that
it's amazing it's really cool it's
amazing i don't understand how it became
that
right which is even more fascinating to
me right you know
uh but yeah i mean yeah it's
unbelievable
the only thing i want to say today is if
we're enjoying this check out taste buds
it's our other podcast on the no
pressure network
me and joe derosa argue foods it is fun
as hell and if you want to be on this
party train you jump on that party train
and god bless you there you go
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
[Music]